let's talk about just briefly about the
p brt or high tech chure p brt is not
exactly the renderer that we are going
to use we're going to use Lux render but
lacks render was built upon p brt and
therefore the basic structure remained
completely intact and this is a really
good architecture that you would see
that many of the rendering engines out
there global illumination rendering
engines out there use most of them used
the very same architecture so we have a
main sampler render task that asks the
sampler to provide random samples so the
sampler you can imagine as a random
number generator we need a lot of
different random members because the
pixel that we are sampling some
techniques choose it deterministically
going from pixel to pixel some
techniques take pixels randomly I mean
which pixel we choose to be sampled is
usually deterministic but the
displacement because we would be
sampling the pixels not in not only in
the mid point like recursive ray-tracing
but you would take completely random
samples from nearby and use filtering to
sum them up in a meaningful way now this
requires random numbers they come from
the center you would also send outgoing
race in the hemisphere of different
objects
you also need random numbers videos so
in this sample these random numbers
arrive and this sample you would send to
the camera and the camera would give
back to you array so you tell the camera
please give me a rate at point to this
pixel and this camera would give you
back array which starts from the camera
starting point end points exactly there
now all you need to do is give this rate
to the integrator and the integrator
will tell you how much radiance is
coming along this rate and what you can
do after that is write it to a film and
this is not necessarily trivial because
for instance you could
simply write it to a ppm or a PNG file
and be done with it in contrast what
what Alexander does is it has a film
class and what you can do is that you
can save different for instance
different contributions in different
buffers so what you could do is for
instance separate direct and indirect
illumination into different fields
different images and then you can in the
end sum them up but maybe you could say
that I don't need caustics on this image
and then you will just pop that image so
you can do tricky things if you have it
correctly implemented to them class ok
so locks wonder just what I have been
talking about it's built upon TV RT and
uses the very same architecture this is
how it looks so it has a graphical user
interface and you can also manipulate
different tone mapping algorithms in
their different denoising image
denoising algorithms in there and you
can even manipulate light groups this is
another tricky thing with the film class
basically what this means is that you
save the contributions of different
light sources in two different films by
films you can imagine image files so
every single light source has a
different PNG file if you will and they
are saved into there and the final image
would come up as a sum a sum of these
individual films but you could say that
one of the light sources is a bit too
bright I would like to tone it down but
if you want to tone it down then you
would have to render your image because
you change the physical properties of
what's going on now you can do this if
you have this light groups option
because they are stored into individual
buffers so you can just dim one of these
images and just add them up together and
then you would have the effect of that
light source a bit dimmer you can for
instance completely turn off sunlight or
a television that you don't that you
don't want to use in the scene it
sounded like a good idea but it wasn't
you can't
turn it off without rendering the scene
and you can operate all of these things
in the through the lux render GUI now
before we go into algorithms let's talk
about algorithm classes what kinds of
algorithms are we interested in first
what we are interested in is consistent
algorithms consistent means that if I
use an infinite number of Monte Carlo
samples then I would converge exactly to
the right answer I would get back the
exact integral of the function
intuitively it says if I run this
algorithm sooner or later it will
converge it also is important to note
that no one said anything about when
this sooner or later happens so if an
algorithm is consistent it doesn't mean
that it is fast it doesn't mean that
it's slow it can be anything absolutely
anything it may be that there is an
algorithm that's theoretically
consistent so until after an infinite
amount of samples you would get the
right answer but it really feels like
infinity so it may be that after two
weeks you still don't get the correct
image there are algorithms like that and
theoretically that's consistent that's
fine because you can prove that it's
color converts sooner or later the more
difficult class that many people seem to
mess up is unbiased algorithms now what
does it mean if you just read the
formula then you can see that the
expected error of the estimation is zero
and we have to note that this is
completely independent of N and is the
number of samples that we have taken now
the expected error of the estimation is
zero it doesn't mean that the error is
zero because it's independent of the
number of sample it doesn't mean that
after one sample per pixel I get the
right result it says that the expected
error is zero I will give you many
intuitions of this for this because it
is very easy to misunderstand and
misinterpret because in statistics there
is a difference between expected value
and
variance and this doesn't say anything
about the variance this only tells you
about the expected values so for
instance if you are a mathematician and
and and think a bit about this then you
could say that if I have an unbiased
algorithm and I have two noisy images
you render something on your machine I
render something in my machine that's
too noisy images I could merge them
together I could average them because
they are unbiased samples it doesn't
matter where they come from I would add
these samples together average them and
I would get a better solution we will
see an example for that
my favorite intuition is that the
algorithm has the very same chance of
over and under estimating the integrand
so it means that if I would try to
estimate the outcome of a dice roll the
expected value you can you can roll from
one to six with equal probabilities the
expected value is three point five so
this means that I would have the very
same probability of saying four as I
would have the probability for saying
three so it's the very same chance to
under and overestimate the integrand and
I'll give you my other favorite
intuition this is what journalists tend
to like the best it means that there is
no systematic error in the algorithm the
algorithm doesn't cut corners and if
there are errors in the image then this
can be only noise and this noise comes
because you don't have enough samples
and if you add more you're guaranteed to
get better now let's take another look
at this really good intuition so I can
combine together two noisy images so
this means that I should be able to do
Network rendering without actually using
a network which sounds a bit
mind-boggling and I really like the
parallel to this which is a famous
saying of Einstein from long ago where
they talked about sending
electromagnetic waves out and they
talked about the telephone and people
could not grasp the
idea of a telephone and he said that we
would have a super super long cat won
the tail of the cat would be in
Manhattan and if you would just pull the
tail of the cat in Manhattan
then the front of the cat would be in
New York and if you pull the tail in
Manhattan then she would say meow in New
York and he asked the people is this
understandable yes this is
understandable okay
perfectly almost there now imagine that
there's no cat and this is the exact
same thing so this is network rendering
without an actual network well okay
mathematical theories okay but let's
actually let's give it a try so what I
did here is I render this interior scene
and this is how it looks like after two
minutes it's really noisy right now what
I did is I ran ten of these rendering
processes and save the images ten times
so I didn't run one rendering process
for long I ran many completely
independent rendering processes four to
two minutes and what I did is I merged
the images together what it means is
that I Everage the images I added them
together and averaged them now basically
this means that you could do this on
completely independent computers that
have never heard of each other and now
let's take a look this is the noisy
image that we had and now let's merge
ten of these together this is what we
will get look closely look at that now
one more time
this is the noisy after two minutes and
this is merging some of these noisy
images together so this is unbelievable
that this actually works so if you have
unbiased algorithms you can expect this
kind of behavior and you don't need to
write sophisticated networking to use
your path tracer for instance in a
network because you don't need to
network at all and this is really
awesome
no because if you don't add any kind of
seed to your computations then you are
computing completely independent samples
and it doesn't matter if the sample is
computed on the same machine or in a
different machine if you have some kind
of determinism then it may be possible
that the same paths are computed by
multiple machine and that's indeed
wasted time but otherwise it works just
fine now let's practice a bit instead
there's nothing in terms of samples
nothing that the only difference is that
you actually need to fire up that seam
on multiple machines so if there is like
10 gigabytes of textures then it takes
longer to load it up on multiple
machines and and neatly transfer the
data together but if you if you think
only in terms of sample it doesn't
matter where it comes from ok let's
practice a bit we have different
techniques and this is how the error is
evolving in time now the intuition of
consistent means that the error tends to
zero over time so if I render for long
enough then the error is going to be
zero is this black one a consistent
algorithm
note because it converges here to the
dashed line and not to zero now what
about the other two guys are they
consistent or not okay so the error
seems to converge to zero okay now what
about these techniques are they biased
or unbiased which is which what about
this one this is the darker gray is this
biased or unbiased now if we have this
intuition that if we render four more
the image is guaranteed to get better or
at least not worse then this dark gray
is definitely not unbiased because it is
possible that I'm rendering for ten
minutes that's this point for instance
and I say okay I almost have a good
enough image and I render for another
five image and expect it to be better
and then I get this may be a completely
garbled up image full of artifacts and
there's and that is entirely possible
with biased algorithms no one said that
it's likely but it is possible so you
cannot really predict how the error
would evolve in time and if you take a
look at the other two lines you can see
that they are unbiased algorithms so as
you render for longer you are guaranteed
to get a better image